[Music]
hey everyone this is part two of our
discussion with Bryan Caplan it picks up
right where we left off in part 1
welcome back there's this study that
came out recently a journal of public
economics which I'm sure you've heard
about oh yeah Aarti Agha I believe is
how you pronounce their name it's called
The effect of human capital on earnings
and so just to summarize briefly a
school in columbia knocked down some of
the classes the advanced coursework for
a couple of degrees it looked like
everybody came in the same so the signal
was still strong enough but lo and
behold in the years following this sort
of reduction in the coursework which
would have denigrated the human capital
component of the the courses of the
course of study but not the signal and
she finds that the employability of
students went down and so did their
wages alright now this is sort of runs
right into your argument how do you how
do you work with that and what do you
think about it and is it sort of a
partial explanation how does it refine
your argument yeah so what I say is
first of all it seems like this is a
very high-quality paper very careful and
I have no fundamental complaint with
exactly was done the main question that
occurs to me is this if it came out the
other way with people then say ah was
the paper that shows that Brian has the
whole thing I don't think so I think if
it came out the other way people would
say well it's a study based upon one
school in Colombia for two majors and it
just tells us a little bit of tells us a
lot about that school and those majors
but doesn't tell us very much about the
education system in general and that is
my view now if you look at the precise
classes that were cut it's very
remarkable that one of the things that
got cut was the econometrics basically
the statistical training that was the
advanced courses then cut and and and so
they also cut a class of Marxist
economics if I remember correctly so I
doubt that i doubt that matter to the
employers but they cut one of the most
vocational classes and that and in fact
I know so they only give as the paper
was this was described to me like maybe
of some of the employer said well we
weren't happy that they didn't know the
statistics anymore remember I never said
that
all the education that all the education
school signalling I'm totally open
totally open-minded about like is this
particular thing signaling your human
capital what's the breakdown but at the
same time what I try to do in the book
is to bring together all the evidence
simultaneously between two covers and
say what is a reasonable breakdown
overall even though yeah so I think the
statistics classes are especially in
like in the modern in the modern big
data economy I think that probably does
have a much bigger relevant to the job
even they are just striking how much of
the of statistics classes are pure
theory and how little of it is actually
get in front of a computer and work with
some data indeed yeah more people should
learn Stata in my opinion yeah
definitely yeah so let me ask a
different question to kind of push back
there's in my field of education we have
lots of studies that look at teacher
value-added right so teacher value-added
is how much difference did this teacher
make to students learning by controlling
when they came in and and some teachers
are much better and others are less and
you know Raj Chetty has also found that
these value-added effects almost
unbelievably last way out into economic
outcomes as adults so how does that
square with this that you know it's all
signalling when it looks like we've
actually got pretty clear signals of
value well they call it value-added yeah
yeah so the way that Raj Chetty does the
work if you look at it closely is he
gets a big payoff for teachers by going
and multiplying 30 kids per class times
a 40-year career that's right
so the actual change on individual kid
of their earnings is actually of getting
a good versus bad teacher it's quite
small and I'd say it's totally within
the realm of what I'm talking about you
know in the book I talk about how some
majors pay more than others some kinds
of courses play more they pay more than
others and II and part of that is
probably that some majors and courses
actually are more skill based and less
and less signally and I'm perfectly
willing to say that some teachers
actually are doing or provide and
pouring more skill on the kids what's
weird about a lot a lot of this
value-added work is very often they find
that the actual cognitive skills fade
out in a couple years but the earnings
don't right right and that's the kind of
thing that I think really should make us
scratch our heads and say what in the
world is going on so you get a good
teacher they teach you more and then a
few years later you've forgotten it but
then 15 years later you get a better job
hmm let's see
seems kind of odd as it is and as for
what's going on they are you know like
to my mind the best story is that when
you get a good teacher they actually are
helping you to help you having trained
you to game the system right so maybe
that you get a you've got a good teacher
yes you get a good teacher and they get
you involved when they say they teach
you better you don't you can't keep the
actual learning but you but they do help
push you up into the more college
motivated track and then you wind up
getting a yo-yo getting more years of
education you wind up says so I mean I'm
so let me try an alternative yep so
again like you know so at least at least
my tentative explanation for these
Chetty results is that having a good
teacher is a lot like going to an SAT
prep class it isn't really improving you
in any fundamental way but it does give
you a leg up in the rat race sure so I
understand that but let me offer another
interpretation and see if you how you
push back on it so what if we Lou we
have some regression or loss over time
because sort of the specifics that would
yield to a higher test score that leads
to higher attention in other words you
know there's a there's a thousand
details and originally you remembered
900 of them and then down the line you
learn you can only remember 700 but
maybe there's some sort of more general
benefit to education that is valued in
the labor market that is valued further
down the line that is transmitted but
not reflected in those narrow narrow
tests that are focused more on see these
discrete particles of education is that
is that possible or likely it's possible
but unlikely so there's a whole field
called Educational Psychology they try
to go and measure the sutler or indirect
effects of learning and education and in
general even though the researchers want
to find the results that there are lots
of subtle and indirect benefits of
education they have a lot of trouble
actually doing it you know like often
they'll work on it for 20 or 30 years
they think they're gonna finally find
the subtle effects and then at the end
they're shell-shocked and they say just
don't see them I wish they were there
you know again it's just so it is a very
striking result and again like when when
academics who want to find a result
can't find it that's the kind of
research that I take very seriously
seems like learning turns out to be
highly specific and again the way that
you train someone to be good at
something is to train them at that exact
task a rower related tasks rather than
just going to give them a general
education I mean especially since the
test that these kids are usually be
given are are not like tests of like the
different five different kinds of clouds
or something like that normally these
are you know our literacy and numeracy
tests right so if the improvement that
you get a literacy and numeracy from a
good teacher if that goes away then
there's still something else that do
some invisible thing again of course
there's this general idea of teaching
people how to think again the old when
people actually try to measure the
ability teach people how to think
they're usually very disappointed it's
really hard to teach people how to think
much easier to actually teach them what
to think right and and again you like
when people often say well the promo of
our education system is we're pouring
tons of action in them we're out
teaching real thinking skills and my
response is you're an optimist I think
it'd be a huge improvement if we
actually talked them a lot of facts we
don't seem to even be able to do that
well let's take another couple of angles
that I think are really interesting so
you make some observations in the book
about this criticism that you know
colleges are far to left but we see what
signaling might predict not what human
capital Theory might predict about that
and we also have some other things that
are interesting that are just one name
off and let's Janet our health effects
of Education civic engagement these are
effects of education that you know when
I've taught classes before I've run
through these bivariate correlations and
said see yes it's better can you just
comment on some of those things and and
how signaling explains them sure so just
starting with the left wing orientation
of t-shirts and especially professors
family on that to be the case
I'll you know certainly certainly higher
education is overwhelmingly true and
again especially for professors that you
would be most concerned about so
basically oppressors and the social
sciences humanities very politically for
our left and so in terms of just being
concerned I can see why people be
concerned that there'd be a lot of
left-wing brainwashing going on in
college and then if you look at K
through 12 teachers it's no
as lopsided but still pretty pronounced
but I see as we go and look at the data
what you see is there's only a very
slight tendency for people with more
years of education to be more liberal
actually now it's easy to think what
that can't be true cuz all my professors
are so liberal may have lots of
education yeah but most well-educated
people aren't professors right there's a
lot of well-educated people who go to
school and then they leave and they do
something else and then we don't really
talk about them anymore because they're
not really politically in our eye
anymore so now again you might look at
this and say see you like you know even
though lately the what's horrible false
accusations to make against left-wing
teachers to claim the trying to
brainwash their students sure they're
actually just doing a good job and
trying to give them an education and
putting their own biases aside I've been
in school too long to believe this story
I see tons of evidence of bias in the
classroom but what I think is really
going on is that most teachers and
professors just aren't very persuasive
they're so boring they're just not very
effective they're not good propagandists
I mean in college half the kids don't
show up to class anyway sure so the fact
that we don't see very much brainwashing
going on I think it's something that
should really make everyone sleep easier
because it means that people that feel
like they're getting accused of
brainwashing really they aren't do at
least aren't accomplishing very much and
the people feel like they like I can't
send my kid to college they'll get
brainwashed by the left like look look
just you don't need to worry yeah calm
down now that much is half at gotcha so
health affects the all the VEX so yes
healthy s so this would be a different
action so so in my whole life I have
never heard someone say you need to stay
in school so you live longer right and
yet there is a a large body of
researchers that go and try to measure
how much longer will you live and how
much healthier were you feel or weighs
all kinds yes yes so we it's kind of
weird because this is the other like
only only real wonks would ever bring
this argument up but there is a lot of
evidence saying that it's true what you
sow however oh so you like like in Italy
I think I spent at least a full month of
my life just reading this research to
see what I would say about it and at the
end of me like there's a few things and
I say first of all if you go and make a
bunch of reasonable adjustments than a
lot of the effect does go just go away
so and you want to adjust for you first
of all just want to adjust for income
right right so you can use money to buy
health so in the fact that the more
educated people have more money well
like they could have had more money a
lot of different ways so so I can
control for selection
control you want to control for a buncha
different kinds of selection or more or
you'd also just say look it's really
double counting to say the education
raises income income rate income raises
health and then to give the give give
that credit for education would be like
saying education is great because it
gives you a better car well it's right
look look we already counted that when
we were adding up the financial payoff
so we shouldn't count it a second time
the other thing though is that a lot of
these health benefits come from
lifestyle changes and essentially more
educated people have a more cautious and
abstemious lifestyle weights over their
peers yes and their peers and so when
you look at that you say well isn't that
great and I think well is it great so
there's a lot of things you could
actually do to improve your health that
I would highly recommend you not do
because they are horrible fit horrible
things and you'd be giving up so much
like for example if you were just
celibate you're on tour
deny your life you cut out a great many
risks yes yes and you don't recommend
yeah I don't recommend it right you know
so just imagine that education were
basically monastic education returned
people celibates we then say this is a
great health benefits like it's a health
benefit that anyone can access at any
time
it's a horrible cost so the the book is
really provocative it's really
interesting I encourage folks to read it
because there's far more than we can
cover here what do you want people to do
if they buy your argument what do you
want them to do so there's two things
that I push for all right so the first
thing is cutting education spending
educational austerity I say that the
fundamental cause of credential
inflation the fundamental reason why you
need so much education to get a halfway
decent job in America is because there's
so much access to education there's so
many people have it the degrees have
proliferated beyond all beyond all
measure and as a result you now need a
lot to impress employers I say that if
there were less access to education we
would have credential deflation we could
move back to the to the way that the
economy worked in the 60s or 50s where
you get a very good job right out of
high school so you're not for free
college I am very much against free
college I say though those whole
mentality is the problem sure I see oh
so I actually must I have a section
called the hidden wonder of high tuition
and student debt which is of course any
one individual would like to have free
tuition but if everyone at free tuition
this would mean there'd be even more
college degrees out there and the green
would mean even less again when I say
this people get so freaked out because
they're thinking about what about
one poor kid who can't afford to go and
I'm saying look that's not the right
thought experiment the right thought
experiment is what if a ton of people
couldn't afford to go anymore and I say
then a lot of people couldn't afford it
but you wouldn't need it anymore so
imagine a world where you couldn't
afford college but also you could get a
good job without college right that
seems like a much better world for most
people in the world they're in right now
all right so education austerity what
else again the other thing is vocational
education which i think is greatly
undervalued partly it's undervalued just
for individuals because while you're
well college pays well for people who
are good students it doesn't pay well
for people who are not good students
because they especially because they
have such slim odds of finishing yes so
I say you know there's there's a lot of
evidence that for people that just don't
like school and you know people always
say oh they just have the right teacher
no there's a lot of people that with the
best teacher in the world would not make
us history interesting them it's not a
problem with the teacher it's a problem
with the person doesn't like this kind
of thing at all
so you're totally okay if a lot fewer
people take us history yeah no problem I
mean yes so you know like especially
just because there's so little evidence
that adults retain more than more than a
token amount of knowledge so meaning
like you know so if it were if most of
the American adults knew a lot of
history and then I said we don't use it
and someone said yeah what makes them
better voters I'd be nervous but it's
not true that most adults know a lot of
history in fact when they vote yes a lot
more people vote the knew then who have
a decent understanding of history or
civics radio partly because we have the
whole mentality of it doesn't matter how
you vote just vote rather than I say is
a sensible mentality of if you
understand what's going on then please
do participate because you improve
things if you have no idea what's going
on then you're just muddying the waters
but know that but that is going to let
me push it along one last thing that I
think is it yeah that is controversial
that I think you have another book a
book about that isn't that card yeah I
do yeah yes yeah myth LaRoche we'll have
two talking about the myth of the
rational letter another time but
interesting question here as sort of
that I didn't see in the book
what about micro-credentials this is a
talk about is you know sort of
vocational education so instead of a
couple of you know kingpin credentials
high school degree college degree
masters what if we had 30 degrees and
that would give clearer and more
specific signals to the labor market do
you think there's promise there and do
you think there's any way from maybe
this trough of an equilibria to get over
the hump to where we might get
micro-credentials I'm not optimistic
except in some very special cases so
there's some kind of very special
computer skills where you might be able
to get your badge for being proficient
in JavaScript and maybe you can get a
job like that although you might talk to
people at actually the programming
industry usually they say well we're now
really credential Asst back in the 70s
and 80s when the world was swimming with
self-taught programmers we were open
minded but now that almost all the good
people go to college
we are just as narrow-minded as people
as basically every other industry is so
you know like there's always room to try
to go and shave off corners from the
system and try to carve out new areas
where you can go and get a good job
without having there having the standard
credentials but I say you know the
problem is we have this college for all
mindsets so thoroughly ingrained in us
it really is like showing up for an
interview in a swimsuit to go and try to
get a job without a college degree it
just seems so odd and like why are you
trying to weasel out of the normal path
right why can't you just go and do the
normal thing like everybody else what's
wrong with you and it's a hard question
to you way they maybe say well I just
thought I can learn this better by doing
30 micro degrees well yeah so if we
could set if we get all very ill like
simultaneously switch to a world where a
lot of people are doing it the maybe
would work if the problem is right now
are the best the best people generally
want to do the traditional thing and
their parents certainly want them to do
the traditional thing I did colleague
who 10 years ago was really worried but
we were all gonna get put out of
business as professors and I firstly
said calm down everything's gonna be
fine
and then and then I said look what are
you doing simple online education it's
coming could do to us but absolutely did
and and I said look what would you say
10 years from now your son says hey Dad
I'm not gonna go to a regular college
I'm gonna go online and he said no son
of Mines gonna do that exactly right and
that's what all these other parents are
gonna say and that's why you don't we
don't need to worry about losing your
job all right there's no fighting the
education credential industrial complex
well I say that there would be if there
were big cuts in spending because I
think I think that everything is
thinking so he said like a trillion
dollars of government money on the side
of the status quo I think if we get us
have a 10% cut right and there is a lot
of research on how respond
of his college attendance to the price
and there's plenty responsiveness most
the people doing this research want to
make it cheaper because they say see if
we cut the price more people would go I
just take this research my book and I
repurpose it and say see we could get
the number of people who spend all these
years and education down by raising the
price and the social benefit would be
great because it would change the
meaning of the degrees would mean that
you could go again go and get a good job
without a college degree wouldn't that
be a better world more than one where
you need a master's degree to be a
janitor well it's a compelling argument
it's a compelling book thanks for coming
by and talking to us and I'll have to
have you back at another time to talk
about great pleasures thanks so much
awesome thank you thank you hey everyone
this is the end of our viewpoint series
with Bryan Caplan thanks for watching as
always let us know what other topics
you'd like a AEI scholars to cover on
viewpoint and be sure to check out the
rest of our videos and research from AEI